but first up he is planet Earth's most
tireless champion his sequel for the
oscar-winning An Inconvenient Truth is
out now it's called An Inconvenient
sequel truth to power he's also the
author of the companion book truth to
power Al Gore's
[Applause]
Oh Boris they're like the gentle but
okay
okay so I didn't mention oh you got your
cowboy boots on there yeah that's for
the tour we forgot you're from Tennessee
yeah
I didn't mention you're the vice
president you were the vice president in
the United States yep okay great I took
that out of the intro I thought they
knew it anyway so I want to ask about
this movie because back in 2003 James
Hanson said we are approaching a tipping
point now we don't do something in ten
years it's too late
well it's past ten years your first
movie came out in 2006 similar kind of
predictions are we kidding ourselves
about the tipping point
are we moving the tipping point well
people mean different things by the
phrase the the most important meaning is
have we crossed a point of no return
where this thing spins out of control
and the scientists still tell us no we
have not gotten to that point we can
still avoid the most catastrophic
consequences if we start acting boldly
now and we have begun to start but some
tipping points have unfortunately been
passed I'll give you an example a very
large part of the West Antarctic Ice
Sheet just years ago they said okay
that's crossed the tipping point it is
now gonna be gone no matter what we do
and that actually hit me pretty hard
when that news came out because it it
does mean that there's going to be
considerable sea level rise no matter
what we do but we still have the ability
to control the pace of that
disappearance and sea level rise and we
still have the ability to stop other ice
sheets behind it from crossing now
there's some other tipping points that
are kind of uncertain we're taking huge
dangerous risks now that we should not
be taken so when the sea levels rise
with obviously we could lose like Venice
we could lose Florida yeah I just and
who would know better about losing
Florida
[Applause]
Carrie Florida that's right okay there
are a lot of coastal cities that are
gonna face a real danger and I went to
Miami din to make a movie I saw a fish
from the ocean swimming in the streets
just because it was high tide and by the
way this week they had more than six
inches of rain in two hours and it
flooded again for a different reason
connected to the climate crisis the
Norfolk Virginia the largest naval base
in the world is going to have to be
moved because of sea level rise
Galveston you can go down the list but
the big danger is for poor people in
places like Bangladesh and Calcutta and
Mumbai right and you know when you talk
to Republicans about this they seemed to
have a couple of talking points that
they always go to one of them is why
should we do anything because china
isn't hmm that's not true right not not
anymore so address all these yeah the
China is doing something another one of
them is it's gonna cost jobs it's it's
it's bad for the economy that's not
really true not turn the other one is
the science isn't really settled all
these are bogus are they not yeah they
are China is implementing a
cap-and-trade program right now closing
hundreds of coal burning plants building
more solar farms than anybody else by
far India by the way has done a u-turn
since the Paris agreement and they're
moving we personally negotiated that
well there are a lot of people
I was I was happy to be asked to help by
Christiana Figueres and other leaders of
that conference and I like to think it
did some good but India just announced
that within only 13 years 100% of all
their new cars and drugs are going to
have to be electric vehicles that's more
than we're doing public transportation
as for jobs solar jobs are now growing
17 times faster than other jobs in the
economy the single fastest growing job
is wind turbine technician the real
bright spot a spot for creating jobs in
higher wages is in renewable energy and
the sustainability solutions we ought to
be investing in that to put more people
to work but like you know Trump was in
West Virginia again the other day yeah I
guess it was yesterday you know
whenever he's down they they put up in
front of one of these rallies usually in
a place like that and he promises them
they're gonna go back into the mines he
said are there any Russians here in
Russia when they said you're gonna go
into the mines it's a threat here it's a
reward I don't understand why people
want to go back into the mines it has to
be the worst job in the world
well the coal companies themselves
eliminated most of those jobs with
mechanization and cheap natural gas from
fracking came in and finished off most
of the rest of the industry it's it's
not coming back but we have an
obligation to those miners they and
their predecessors did helped to build
this country they ought to be getting
the training they need and getting the
opportunities that are okay now okay so
why can't
why can't Democrats sell that to them
that we could retrain you for a job that
you probably would like better than
being in a dark hole where you the life
expectancies about 15 years less than
everybody else yeah for probably a
better wage yeah we ought to be able to
and we ought to get back to the kind of
social contract we once had to recognize
that some of these economic changes are
not going to be under our control the
world is moving on but we owe it to
people who are hurt by the transition to
give them the opportunities that that
they need to find new and better jobs
absolutely
[Applause]
so okay so Trump wants to pull out of
the Paris Accord something which you
know I always say the kind of people who
would negotiate the Paris Accord these
are the people if you get the medals
because it just cannot be easy to get a
hundred ninety countries and whatever it
is saying with Keota which you were very
involved at out 90s on the same page
this is tedious work you know that
people should get a clap on the back for
okay he wants to pull out we thought
maybe when you went to Trump Tower and
talked to Ivanka about it she yes I did
and I talked to the the then
president-elect and that conversation
continued after he went into the White
House and I thought actually there was a
chance he might come to his senses but I
was wrong and then when he made his
speech pulling out of Paris I really was
concerned that some other countries
might use that as an excuse to pull out
themselves but the very next day the
entire rest of the world redoubled their
commitment to the Paris agreement
almost had a salutary effect yeah it did
you know in in politics there's a law
that comes out of physics that sometimes
works for every action there's an equal
and opposite reaction
and it happened here in this country
Jerry Brown in California Andrew Cuomo
in New York other governors mayors
business leaders stepped up to fill the
gap and said we're gonna meet the
commitments under the Paris agreement
regardless of what Donald Trump does
looks like the country is going to do
that I'm all for states rights ok so let
me ask you about this you say and I
think you're absolutely right about this
that we have to if we're gonna fix
climate we have to fix our democracy
yeah first now when you won / lost the
election you got 500,000 more votes than
the guy who took over Hillary got three
million more yeah this trend is not
going in the right direction now this
thing where we get the most votes and
they get to be President that's a
pattern now and it's not going in the
right direction how do we stop that well
I do think it's time to get rid of the
electoral college and go
[Applause]
but what's a constitutional amendment
that well it no that's one way to do it
there's also an initiative to have a
compact among the states it started here
in California it could work but even
more importantly than that we have to
get big money out of politics they the
lobbyists and the fat cat contributors
hacked our democracy before Putin hacked
our democracy right and we need to
defend it and and put the people back in
control and we can do that okay and
finally you know I think we're totally
on the same page here that we have to
talk to younger people who think somehow
that someone's gonna come up with a
great invention that's gonna solve
cloture yeah you know I did a long thing
here one night about Mars Mars is not
the backup plan yeah no one wants to
live on Mars I got a lot of pushback
from Millennials saying you know you're
anti science see I'm not anti science
cuz I don't want to live on a planet
with no air you got to make it here
there's no backup plan right yeah that's
one of the points I'm making this movie
I'm all for exploring Mars that's an
exciting prospect but like you I'm
against the illusion that we've got a
backup planet and we're gonna move to
something we couldn't even evacuate New
Orleans whenever
thank you so much for what you do
you are the tireless champion of this
cause you had it right all those years
ago and you know you never stop Thank
You Al Gore
[Applause]
[Music]
see the movie yes go see that my hair
ran out very soon